Courtney what is your process for taking
characters that are written in the
script which they may not have much
description but then it's your job to
kind of visually bring them alive what's
your process for that well I think when
you are a designer or a visual person to
begin with when I'm reading I'm just
seeing images you know it's just it's
just coming to me and whether ultimately
those images end up being completely
wrong or dead on it just starting off
place so when you start read a script I
mean you know the hateful eight is a
very special circumstance because of the
way the Quinton writes his scripts I
mean he writes his scripts in so many
ways like for his crews because what
happens between the dialog is as good as
the dialogue you know it's like it opens
and it's like inglorious 70-millimeter
you know you're just there and and you
feel like everything you see unlike so
many scripts that you do turn out to be
as amazing or better than what you could
imagine them to be whereas so many times
you read script and you see it and
you're like oh hi in my head but one in
my head was so good
well the what I'm Quinton said is
obviously gonna beat any of ours so I
start to read it and while I'm reading
it I see images so whether you know it
starts talked about Bob the Mexican and
all of a sudden thinking about Eli
Wallach and you know the good the bad
and the ugly or you know you're reading
something when you hear believe and
Cleve you know was one of the references
in the script for Sam Jackson's
character major Warren and I'm thinking
okay is that Lee Van Cleef in the big
gun down is it Lee Van Cleef and so you
know I just immediate imeem I also came
with of Leon a Western a wealth of
knowledge because my first film I ever
designed was a Western four hundred
thousand dollar Western called dead
man's burden so I am pretty versed in
Western so it's it's already a language
you pull from I mean we all know say
clothes because you get dressed in the
morning so if you read a contemporary
movie you might think well that reminds
me of that shirt I have or you know oh
that kind of messy that girl I knew in
high school or that character really
raised me that boss I had that I really
didn't like so I'm always doing that
you know if whether it's contemporary or
period you know and then you think about
other movies you know and you think well
that kind of reminds me of you know
Rebecca or you know whatever it is
depending on the period
you're eating and then from there you
start to gather the image the images
physically that are in your head so when
I go to interview for the hateful eight
I mean I went very over-the-top but I
was like I'm getting this job I
researched you know I had a ton of real
images of people in the eighteen
hundreds you know late 1800s when
photography started becoming available
the klondike expositions expeditions in
the early 1900s we're all in the snow so
there was some really great imagery
there and then also working with movies
okay so what movie references it's
Quentin he wants to hear what movies
you're thinking about so what movies I'm
pulling from and then actual furs and
then I what fur I found that I thought
would be cool or what images I found I
worked with the Autry archives to get
actual historical pieces that we could
revamp or create recreate that's John
Roos coat is actually from there and so
then you you know you're building what's
in your head physically for someone to
see and a lot of times even if it's
totally wrong it's the start of the
conversation and directors are visual
people so getting them the visuals to
say oh hey I never thought about that
type of hat that wasn't what I imagined
but maybe let's see it you know so
working from there to give them
something to react to because they don't
have the language that we have they
don't they like I did a Terrence Malick
movie and like he just kept he was
talking at the designer and he just kept
saying like Jersey just make everything
be in Jersey and so you're you have to
say like what does that mean to him is
it that it's soft is it that it's slinky
you know what what is jerky but you know
they have this vocabulary that's like
what that Quinton I love he's always
like this this pounds tooth and I'm like
you don't that's not but it's it's cool
just to try to excavate what they're
seeing without them having that
vocabulary always sure so when you have
this visual and you're getting feedback
from the director how much do you let
the actual the actor also help shape
this character and say you know what
this doesn't actually feel right or yes
this does I mean if they're they have of
course opinions that we want honor on a
Quinton movie it's a little different
because Quinton is physically in the
fittings with you so a lot of times that
have
you have a meeting with the director of
the directors like I see this character
this one way and I see is you know go
get great so I pull based on that
because they're my boss and then you get
into the fitting room and the actors
like oh no I didn't think that this was
what I see this as and so now you're the
go between these two parties so Quinton
unlike most directors is in the room
because he is the creator he is the
mother of these characters so if he's
giving birth to them he's gonna be there
to watch them take their first step and
that's literally what a fitting is and I
think I think Robert DeNiro told to him
a long time ago that he finds his
character when he puts on his shoes and
Quinn thought well if I wrote that
character why wouldn't I be there when
they put on those shoes and so he's
there and and that really takes out the
middleman so if the actor is like you
know I don't but if quits saying that he
thinks something is right they're gonna
go along with it you know he really is
he's the or you know he's the
orchestrator of all of this so everyone
is pretty receptive to if his opinion
you know obviously he'd never forced an
actor and something that felt terribly
wrong but everyone knows it's gonna be
right because it's coming from his head
you know right so then how does he know
and how do you all know that the
character is ready obviously when he
says well he has it in his head you know
I think so much of the job of working
with Quinton is excavating what is that
image in your head and a lot of times he
doesn't necessarily know it until he
sees it but it's sort of the trial and
error of okay you know major Warren was
a perfect example because originally
okay he's been up in the mountains he's
bounty hunting he you know so I had
pictured originally that he was a little
more of like a wilderness man you know a
little bit more of a man of the
wilderness like you know some fur ankle
trap you know they and and and and some
handmade stuffing and he had kind of
taken his uniform and turned it into a
wilderness very you know version of
himself and and then in the end we kept
feeling like well that doesn't feel
quite right you know it just doesn't and
we were trying that and we tried this
other angle we try this so there you go
and then Quinton had the image of them
there's a Western called SART Anna's a
spaghetti western series and start and
we always have said okay Lee Van Cleef
so what is Lee Van Cleef we Van Cleef is
a tie and a vest and a brocade vest that
fits perfectly and a straight hat and
we'd already had the hat in the jacket
but it was filling out those pieces and
then when we when he was out Sour tan at
that bright red that bright yellow and
we started to pull it together it really
it became major worrying you know and
that was that was different than other
characters other characters come very
easily Bob the Mexican on my interview I
went to chimayo informing around two
chimayo New Mexico and I picked up the
textiles that were later to become Bob's
vests which are hand-woven textiles from
their culture Mayan textiles from
chimayo New Mexico and I said could you
ever replicate this ten times because we
needed ten of everything and the Weaver
was like maybe you know if we modify the
design there was and so you know that
was before I even interviewed that was
my vision in my head is like okay I was
Mexican I wanted to be Mexican you know
I wanted to feel that and so you know
they're not it's not always that do I go
to the left and I go right do we go
underground we go over the idiot wall to
figure it out basically you're
excavating the character from the script
wading through a director's vision and
an actor's opinion and that's a really
exciting process I think I read about
you that you are very into the power of
manifestation I think there was like a
post-it note that things happen for you
I am as my mom says once I've made up my
mind that I want to do something I want
some things you're like well forget it
like you're doing it because I really
believe I mean obviously I'm here and so
grateful to be here because I saw it you
know I wanted it and and when I first
read the script I thought like this is
an amazing opportunity to dive in to
this next level of filmmaking but still
have an intimate enough cast to really
do the work that I'm excited to do and
show off what I'm capable of doing while
honoring such a tremendous story and the
thing about Quentin is you know the
actors benefit from the fact that he's
not hiring the hottest person with the
best resume with this with of that he's
hiring the right person for a job so
that's how while Goggins is Chris Mannix
it wasn't cuz walkins is a giant movie
starts because while Goggins is Chris
Mannix and we are all the benefactor you
know that benefactors of this generosity
of spirit of his intuition of knowing
that someone is right for something and
that I feel so endlessly grateful for
the opportunity to be able to show in
the world to what I'm capable of
you know well keeping with the
manifestation I think you also said that
you would love to have a costume that
you've designed in a museum or the
ArcLight
so my two little rear goals were like
you to my short term you know it's like
oh I just one day I want my I want
someone to dress as my character for
Halloween because I just thought
wouldn't that be the most amazing thing
to be walking around on Halloween and be
like I designed that and then the other
one was to have my costumes in the lobby
of the ArcLight and now I think that
they will be in the ArcLight but they're
also being I'm put in the permanent
exhibit of the Autry museum of western
heritage and you know Sam Jackson's
costume it seems it's you know major
Warren and Daisy and and John Ruth and
it's really exciting it's also really
exciting that Sam's costume will be
there because there is not obviously a
lot of diversity it's western heritage
so it's like John Wayne and every other
amazing Gene Autry ever their amazing
white dude wore a great costume and it's
really cool to be able to say that I
helped you know design these costumes
that will be there any favorite that if
you had to choose that one person you're
gonna see instead on Santa Monica
Boulevard next Halloween oh you know
actually I saw there already was up to
people at dressed as the costume
Halloween and then it was Daisy and they
did Obi with the balls on the hat
they're like tape balls I was like
picture and I was like it's already
happened so I think you know obviously
the costumes I I thought about the sod
and I'm like God I kind of designed
complicated costume people to try and
recreate but I believe they can do it so
I think major Warren's would be great
just getting that white in that red and
that yellow would be really fun to see
it I think that I think it'd be a really
fun couples costume if they did John
Ruth and Daisy gonna be just great but a
good luck finding that Buffalo go right
right well I know you also said that you
feel and I'm not sure if I'm saying this
right way but that anyone was sort of
tenacity and and willpower can get
anything done yeah so what would you
advise someone maybe
coming out of Tish or even who hasn't
gone to college but they would like to
somehow get involved what's the first
step yeah they move you know whenever I
meet with people who are interested in
getting into costumes the first thing I
always ask is who are your favorite
designers so the first step is knowledge
know who in your field or who in your
aspiring field you want to be you know I
want to be calling out would I want to
be Sandeep a light these are women who
I've I do what I do because of their
work and you know so you know that and
you see that and then from there
acquiring like the skills
so after you've acquired the knowledge
you know because whenever you meet
people especially in our fields where
were faceless people you know we're
faceless people so your name you know Oh
Colleen Atwood what it would be like to
be caught you know and you don't even
when I was younger I once stood next or
in line in a bathroom and I didn't know
it and it was like my biggest regret of
my career was like I didn't talk to her
in that moment by the bathroom and then
she called me to work for her for end up
working for her for two years
and like years later and I was like my
boobs okay that I didn't gush at her in
a bathroom but knowing who those people
are that you have that you can see that
you want to be and then learning from
them you know and the reality is if you
approach anyone and you say I would do
anything for you and I'll do it for free
and I'll do it you know save that money
to be able to just get in the room with
those people I'm Jacqueline West gave me
a really big break on Water for
Elephants by putting in charge of all
the backgrounds of a period circus movie
and I feel so grateful but it was
because I was like I will drive to
wherever you are I will mow your lawn
whatever you need me to do I will do it
so you know know who you want to be and
then try and be in a room with them and
try and learn from them get them coffee
it doesn't matter you know no one is
gonna say no to that type of passion and
that type of you know endearment alright
so your mission statement is my mission
statement is you know see the prize you
know see what you want and then be smart
about it you know and be I always say
you know be like I used to call the
designers girls and I'd say like I am I
just ran into so-and-so and I need their
email and I haven't ever even met them
because I just wanted to be able to
reach out to these people I need
none of those emails are responded to
even if you've put it into the universe
I always say I've sent thousands of
emails into the universe that were never
responded to and I'm here because they
were responded to in that way that makes
excellent that's excellent